well for the time being spider-man is
officially out of the MCU and back over
at Sony's spider-verse how's it going
everybody it's Warren and if you haven't
heard the news yesterday Sony
unfortunately came out with a public
statement and said for the moment the
door is closed on any type of deal with
Disney for spider-man officially
claiming that spider-man will no longer
be a part of the MCU this is obviously
very upsetting news and we've heard many
people from Marvel's reactions to this
over the past few weeks while this
Disney and Sony deal was going on
including reactions from Tom Holland
himself and Kevin Feige the president of
Marvel Studios but throughout this whole
thing a lot of people were wondering
well what do the Russo brothers think
about this whole thing after all the
Russo brothers were the ones who cast
Tom Holland as spider-man for Civil War
it was the Russo brothers Kevin Feige
and Amy Pascal they are the ones who
specifically chose Tom Holland to play
an MCU spider-man so what is their
reaction to know more spider-man in the
MCU well luckily for us they have
actually spoken up about it and we're
going to talk about what they said in
this video reminder if you'd like a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 be
sure to subscribe to my channel like the
video and comment with your favorite
superhero or villain to enter my
giveaway so at the Venice Film Festival
in an interview with The Daily Beast the
Russo brothers were asked how they felt
about Tom Hollands spider-man not being
a part of the MCU anymore well of course
the Russo brothers were sad to see Tom
Hollands spider-man leave the MCU and
they talked about how hard it was in the
beginning for Kevin Feige to even get
Sony on board with the partnership Joe
Russo commented Kevin Feige went through
a lot there were a lot of ups and downs
and he kept walking into our office and
we'd go look we've got to do it with
Sony and he'd go okay I'll figure it out
and walk back into his he was looking
for the way out he wanted to open that
door and have us go we figured it out we
don't need spider-man because it's a lot
of work to get to major corporations to
play nice with each other and the fact
that it happened at all we should all be
dancing and celebrating that we got that
little bit of time then his brother and
co-director Anthony Russo added I think
that's why Joe and I are not so
devastated or surprised that there's
been a falling out because it was so
hard to make it happen in the first
place
so obviously the Russo brothers are
set to see Tom Hollands spider-man leave
the MCU especially since they are the
one who cast him but at the same time
they're not surprised
they watched Kevin Feige from the very
beginning tried to negotiate something
with Sony and apparently Sony was pretty
reluctant to do it in the first place it
sounds like they were being quite
difficult now it's amazing that they did
actually come to a deal because Sony did
not have to let Marvel and Disney you
spider-man in the MCU but ultimately
they did spider-man made his debut in
the MCU and Tom Hollands spider-man
became the most popular spider-man but
of course Sony still owns all the rights
to spider-man and they did not have to
let him appear in the MCU and they don't
have to let him appear in the MCU in the
future so although we should all be
grateful that Sony ultimately let
spider-man appear in the MCU films it
sounds like they've been pretty
difficult from the beginning which is
probably why Sony and Disney could not
come to a deal to keep spider-man in the
MCU so that's it for how the Russo
brothers reacted to hearing the news
that Tom Hollands spider-man is no
longer in the MCU let me know what you
think about what they said about Sony
being very difficult from the very
beginning and do you think that there is
any hope at all for spider-man to come
back to the MCU in the future let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below and don't forget to comment with
your favorite superhero or villain like
this video and subscribe to my channel
so you can enter my giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to the
MCU don't forget to follow me on Twitter
and Instagram and as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof